so this week is school of YouTube where
lots and lots of youtubers are all
learning new skills to show you that
education it's great it's a good thing
and the while unfortunately there are
still lots and lots for millions of
children all around the world who don't
have access to a good education there is
something we can do about that more on
that a little bit later but for now I'm
going to be telling you the tale of how
I learnt to make my very own blend of
quality tea and if you stick around
until the end as well I will also let
you know how you could get some of my
very own tea how about that all for
charity charity so I love tea I have
been searching throughout my entire life
and YouTube career for the perfect cup
of tea but I knew that if I was going to
take my tea making to the next level I
was gonna have to see a professional see
somebody who is even more crazy about
tea than I am enter this guy my name's
Alex probin I'm a master tea blender and
today I'm going to talk you through
process of tasting teens slurping tea
and get you to try a number of different
types of tea taste some flavors that you
think are particularly interesting to
you and hopefully at the end of it
get you to create your own blend then
you can drink as time goes on I didn't
think I realized how excited I would be
the purpose this is kind of a fantasy
country for me that I didn't even
necessarily realize I had now before I
was allowed to make my own blend of tea
I had to learn how to tasty like a true
test taste of master person and
apparently the best technique for doing
that is to be distinctly unpretty and to
slurp as loudly as you possibly can how
I would do it would simply be like this
okay but I've had plenty of practice so
that's like master levels the most level
stuff here you take it a little bit in
NATO we say prymaat stool now that's a
good start
okay it's really good slow thanks game
honestly the tea tasting didn't come
super naturally to me particularly once
it came to the the spitting of the tea
into the spittoon just so nervous
slurping legislation a lot of fresh air
that's it so basically okay don't worry
about dribbling all right there's
nothing I also had quite a lot of
trouble once it came to trying to
describe what the tea actually tasted
like which is kind of the whole point of
tea tasting I know but I did my best
okay
I did my best there's no right or wrong
answer to taste taste is very subjective
so what does it remind you of what is it
what flowers are getting in there if you
just say to me a bit like team there's
no good enough okay a bit like tea is
all I want to say I'm tasting sort of
like floral notes a little bit sort of
hey grassy notes in there
subtle elemental fruitiness do you get
any of that I'd have to try really hard
um takes a lot like water so after lots
and lots of tea tasting we've figured
out the ones that I like the most and
then Alex took me into his factory and
together we created the perfect blend of
tea for me specifically can I take this
home in the end we went with a Sam for
our base black tea then we added some
Earl Grey and lemongrass for some
citrusy notes some black vanilla tea for
a bit of sweetness and some cinnamon red
peppercorns cardamom seeds and ginger to
make it a little bit spicy
once the tea was blended up by my very
own hands I gave it a good sniff
just to make sure I definitely liked it
and then finally it was time for a cup
of tea he's number two you make
lovely that's very very comforting tea
I'm very pleased with that did it I made
tea takes longer here that does it home
I'm going to be honest thank you very
much for watching hopefully you enjoyed
that as much as I did which you didn't
by the way because that was one of the
best days of my entire life just saying
and I also hope you consider donating to
the cause and if you would like an extra
incentive alex is also very kindly said
that he will be making more of my
quality tea my special blend of tea to
give away as perks to people who donate
so if that interests you at all check
out my IndieGoGo page and definitely do
that as well because it's like genuinely
the best cup of tea I've ever had in my
entire life and you get that and you get
to help teach kids at the same time so
don't know why you're still here really
it's a kind of a no-brainer you should
have left by now well you don't go away
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool